[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation hello it's
me Tara Ericson alongside Aon say your
last name so people know Alexander oh he
always says a different that's his full
app name I got aeration y'all wow okay
list comic book character oh I like
comic books but today we're not doing
that we're doing Texas Chainsaw
Massacre if that's s is in this movie I
just I have it inside in my soul but
I've never seen this movie and I like
the I like the stuff guys so I'm a
little scared I'm glad I'm doing it here
I decided I'm going to watch all the
scary movies that I haven't seen I have
to do it here cuz it's in the daylight
with a friend so we're going to do it
now listen you got to get on the patreon
cuz then we call you super sexy oh wait
y'all I need to
rewind you need to leave a like you need
to get in there and you need to leave a
comment and then also don't forget ring
the bell
ring the bell and now get to patreon
okay cuz we call you super sexy over
there you can watch a full length
reaction with me and Aaron we watch the
whole movie we get to see a lot more
than you do on here yeah and we we call
you sexy so like just get on there you
know the juice also Greg and John have
full highlights and reactions over there
on patreon you can check them out
there's a lot more up on there to get
the juice all together and get moving
and grooving okay we love you so much
are you ready to get scared I was yes
that was the longest intro of like
literally my entire life I feel like it
was really long okay we're going to
watch it right
[Music]
now the film which you are about to see
is an account of the tragedy which
befell a group of five youths in
particular Sally Hardesty and her
invalid brother Franklin the events of
that day were to lead to the discovery
of the Texas Chainsaw Massacre okay okay
these are their
stories I'm ready we're ready to be
scared
1973 55 years before I was born yeah
yeah I don't know the math a lot of
years before me too I think what I just
said is I haven't even been born yet but
it's
okay oh that's a foot okay
look so gross
nails okay this look like we're digging
up a dead body yeah the little intro in
the beginning made it feel like more
realistic and this also kind of adds to
that
feeling oh
damn
rough only ofies uh oh wow gross it's
dripping and there's Co cobwebs and just
stringy hair kills me Cemetery just
outside the small rural Texas Community
remains of a badly decomposed body wired
to a large Monument the head or in some
cases the extremities removed the
remainder of the corpse left intact oh
my God no suspects are in custody as the
investigation at the scene
continues oil storage units what a long
shot yeah
one
take what are you willing out of
there
awesome so that's her
brother a piss
yeah oh my God
no
oh
D damn not at hitting him too the
condition of retrogradation is contrary
or inharmonious to the regular direction
of actual movement in the Zodiac and is
in that respect evil what is this
2023 Zodiacs and retrogrades it just
means Saturn's a bad influence it's just
particularly a bad influence now because
it's in retrograde they would fit right
into this year they really would and I
didn't know was sat I always thought it
was Mercury yeah I I don't even know in
retrograde things happen here about they
don't tell
about I see things interesting shot
Franklin don't worry I saw it myself he
did look dug up to me that's your old SL
house that's where grandpa used to sell
his cattle that's where they kill him
they bash him in the head with a big
sledgehammer that's oh God no kill him
on the first
L I'm trying to leave the cows
alone leave him alone and I don't I
don't want to see them drilling hey Cher
should we pick him up oh yeah man pick
him up here let fix out there don't pick
them up don't do that yeah don't you
guys already have enough people in this
van y'all are squished in and sweating
up a storm right oh boy okay they left
him oh no they're not okay it's a horror
movie
I thought they got they got hip to it
they were like it's too hot in here
let's skip
it no I think we just
conflict sketchy ass people oh oh God I
was at the slaughter house I got an
uncle that works at the slaughter house
hey my brother worked there what is my
always been in
me whole family
attrac oh god with the SL [__] see that
was better they died better that way new
way people put out of jobs you do that
look uh all right I want to see this
okay what is it going to be I think let
me see they
don't the and the gums and all the FLH
of the boil down bigy fat that's
nice you'd probably like you didn't know
what was in
it also why is nobody like what's all
that blood all over your face I think
that's a bruise dude a bruise or it's
like a birth mark or something okay yeah
cuz it's like in a pattern I think it'd
be more splattered if it was blood I
just figured maybe he wiped it in a
weird way like
a oh he loves don't do that I don't like
your Vibe bro get out of here hell no
hell to the no no no why we don't get
strangers in the car oh my God what's
going on y'all he's a nice guy oh my
God my God I legit
can't get the F just like sitting there
staring at get the F out of my goddamn
car if he smears it on his face we know
it's blood and not a birth mark this is
why we don't talk to
strangers oh what what I got a knife too
oh God uh I like it no no no no no no
definitely take it take it away from him
get that knife away from him and kick
him out your
car it's a camera and some Taxidermy is
what it
is hell no hell no what you can take me
to my house I live right off this road
nope well I I don't know man we're in
pretty much of a hurry black people
don't do this [__] this a hell no you
just like get him out just we we haven't
stopped you have the numbers get him out
of here you like H Che my brother makes
it real good you like I think we better
push on
that no I don't want to meet your
brother he doesn't sound like a fun guy
neither do
you are they not going to look like them
in the pictures this is so
creepy I'm uncomfortable I'm just shook
that they haven't stopped and been like
you can get out pay him man Frank back
get the [__] out of my
car that's your
payment what the hell is that
aluminum not the aluminium come on God I
thought he was going to start doing
crack or something I'm like oh God what
is he going to do now not the crack is
is he going to do drugs off the
picture what is he doing could you think
of a better time oh my God is it black
tar hero it's black tar what a better
time oh my God I oh my
God oh my God the knife the KN
no
see this is why we don't talk to
strangers pull over the oh my God
y'all oh my
God why are they going so slow oh he's
marked your car you've marked them for
death with his crazy
[Music]
blood call a cop I mean that's what you
get piing up pick up Str fired how did
we not pull over 5 minutes ago
and get him out of the car once he
started opening up his hand with the
blade oh wow they wash your car too
would you fill her up
please fill her up buttercup baby don't
you let me down tanks empty transport
won't be here until late this afternoon
oh you know where the old Franklin Place
is those things is dangerous you're Li
to get hurt oh my father owns it I got
some good barbecue here why don't you
fellas stick around here a while listen
to him everyone in here has a tinge of
like they're a little behind like the
guy with the windows only they want to
know what happens when they go to the
house and T do you know what happens
when he ask stupid questions there's no
stupid questions when you ask stupid
questions he's going to die you win
stupid
prizes hey I bet that's some of that
guy's blood look at that look at that
think didn't just cut me yeah I guess so
you don't say you think you could do
that to yourself like crazy clearly you
are going to this goddamn house do that
to yourself like you God you think I
said something made him
mad
uh yeah cuz it's your fault he's crazy
come on Sally we're going out to place
let's go hey that guy smear blood all
over the van see what I mean everyone's
a little off like the guy with the red
hair only follow that guy around he
would go when he knock in the car he'd
leave and not clean it now he's looking
up in the sky all weird then the guy
with the blood I'm like maybe she's
right about the Saturn and this town
people are I don't know some's off I
don't know some how would he not wipe
the blood yeah that's a well he was just
I guess cuz the guy kept leav and
anytime the guy would leave he would
leave too which I think is great
Direction um you think that guy's just
trying to scare us by you know blowing
up my picture on him no he marked you
for death that's that's what he
did
what that's
weird wonder if that means something
it's a weird looking cigar that's not a
cigar I don't know it's meat right he's
eating like a
meat he's eating like a meat stick me
stick looks like a finger my god get it
out think get it out of your mouth
buddy where's my knife oh hell you took
his godam why is he doing the like the
guy was doing when he got dropped off
there's something going
on oh my God no thank you why is there
so money get out of
here who do you think dies
first I think he lies till the end I
think he's gone I think he's gone got
the weird weird blood in him
though go
no we'll see you in an hour or so you
won't what what the hell is that that
was like a vertebrae a bird nest a bird
bone
Nest oh wow oh wow that's like a like a
ritual looking thing
Sally
Sally hell no this is when we leave this
is when we we continue driving toe of
death yeah the mistletoe of death kissed
by a chainsaw
yeah Sarah have you seen the movie Cabin
in the Woods
no oh my God this is reminding me of
that movie a little bit but you should
definitely watch that oh my
God
where is the noise coming from I'm not
trying to find out I mean I am I a't
trying to go near whatever the hell that
ISAT a generator
electricity oh it's a generator got
it I feel like it's a ter applicable to
most our
movies e that's a to something for
you someone's like getting something
from
hilarious gross you're so funny oh my
God
hello hello feel like guys are really
missing out on the the the jean shirt
just fully open look fully open chest
full of hair
hello get the hell out of that house
tell you these guys are unfaced by all
of it clearly your homie got cut in the
car by a is that what is that
noise that sounds like a pig pig it's a
pig it's a pig jsaw is here I know
it what the
[Applause]
[__] my
God oh my God oh my God oh my God oh my
God oh holy sh oh my God threw him like
a rag doll
[Music]
dude okay obviously that's how the
cattle the cattle suffered he suffered
there moving around this is all
just girl don't just I don't know she
has to get her boyfri no you just you
yell from from the door and if he
doesn't answer you get the F out of
there and you go find your friend
friends cuz there's strength and numbers
don't open that door honey okay well
bye-bye to you too huh adios adios chick
it's been nice knowing
you what what what uh oh bones bones
bones so many feathers bones and
feathers
yeah we don't go in stranger houses that
looks like a human
foot oh boy here we go sounds about
right
yeah yep okay this is so disturbing this
is eerie and uncomfortable and my skin
is
crawling girl I mean get up off the
floor already it's a crown of feathers
on a skull what the what the
hell oh in a turtle shell
no PO
Turtle if you don't get out of that
freaking house dude girl get get up and
go yeah good luck y oh boy yep sounds
about right yep he's so big too like
nothing you should even really do he's
like manhandling her oh my God oh God
where not on the hook not on the
hook oh Jesus
God it just slowly goes
in oh God
what oh in the
chainsaw oh God help us
okay creepy ass mask too oh this is
horrifying how is she still alive where
is that hook this is horrible it's in
her back dude it's
like he's coming to get you you don't
think it means oh it's like a bird it's
like a bird skull oh I can't find my
knife that knife won't do you any good
he likes that knife remember when did
you have it last when the guy was was
cutting you you had it last I gave it to
you remember what' you do with it well I
don't know didn't I give it back to you
you just never gave it back to me all
right I'll look for was that the girl
reading astronomy or was the other girl
it was
the okay I'm happy I'm not alone it was
the other girl it was the other girl
yeah okay cuz she wasn't blonde reading
the
[Music]
book come on victim number three
MH is anybody home we just love doing
dumb things and going to places we
shouldn't hello also isn't that's one of
their jackets I think so or that is that
a
blanket is anybody here I don't think he
was wearing a jacket it might have been
the blanket you're right they took a
blanket with him and I think that's
what's on the porch right he's got to
see that and go oh they're inside all
right are you guys in
there why is this sound I hate
it okay you guys what a weird sound what
is a
sound you're about to get snatched
homie oh they're not there anymore uh
where are they he removed
them are they in the fre they're in the
freezer hell no hell no don't go in
there what the what the she's not dead
what the
jeez
what oh god that noise what is that what
he's freaking out that there's more
people yeah he's making some sort of
[Music]
noise oh God his teeth I can't even look
he's licking
them he crosses me out so much we've got
to go look for
them what if we get lost too
Jerry or the others like if the car had
some gas I'd be driving the van right
now they'll probably be back in a minute
or so Sally we ought to go to that gas
station listen to your boy yeah I mean
that's the only option Sally Sally they
took the keys we don't have any Keys
give me that flashlight I got to take
the flashlight all I'm going to go look
all I'll go with you I'll go with you
all right all right let's go let's go I
I'll go with you don't leave the van on
is going to definitely die now when the
keys aren't in the van the lights are on
though I thought I heard something
there's a light yeah don't follow it run
from it where there's light there's
death hey J don't do it please don't do
it if one of us goes in then we all go
through it we're all going to
die Sally I hear something stop
stop no
oh
that got
me oh my
God okay girl run run just run just run
what are you doing don't stand there
scream run good girl okay oh okay good
on you good on you movie I don't get
jump scared often you got me today that
was a good
one oh out
of the thing and he can cut through the
trees cuz he has a
chainsaw my God yep yep all right here
we go just go just run just run Yep this
is just a thing of nightmares that's for
sure no don't scream he's going to know
where you are run what is she
doing oh my gosh she's stuck being a
dummy get oh good lord get out of
there are you going to the house I don't
know she's going to his house going to
his house oh you got to find all your
friends who are
dead you're going straight to the den
girl yeah lock lock the door not that he
can't just chain through it right or
break all the
windows yeah now you're really in it oh
God what's up you going to cut through
your own door yeah just knock it down bu
kind of counter kick it you're like
61 right you've got enough weight oh my
God what is
[Applause]
that dead Grandpa dead grandma oh my God
this is so disturbing dead dog oh God
[Music]
oh yep you're going to jump out of
window at this point I can only imagine
this tra oh my God she did it you did it
I didn't think that was going to happen
good job you did something kind of smart
oh good job good God job drop the
chainsaw on her like he going to drop
the chainsaw he is he going to just drop
it and it's going to go through no he's
going to go down okay this movie's not
that wacky okay okay all right you just
got to you just got to
[Music]
go damn oh dang oh girl get up get up
come
on oh my God he's right there how is
homie so fast he's right
there he's right behind you so tense
this the guy oh my God you ran that okay
oh my God is it that guy is it the gas
station guy oh oh no it's not okay oh
thank God okay she got some help I don't
know what happened to the other there's
no there what happened to me he just
I'll get the
truck take it
easy leave the door open like that
quiet what what is she looking at what
are you looking
at what is that oh is it the meat I just
cooking the meats they slaughter Meats
yeah the
barbecue is that the body parts from the
cabers that they've been talking about
and he's the guy who's been digging up
bodies and it's not it's not real
barbecue it's it's human barbecue oh
God so creepy oh God I trust nobody and
nothing why did chainsaw guy immediately
stop when we got here rope why you got
rope what is going on what is going on
no there's no need to do that nobody's
going to hurt
you oh my god what is he are you beating
with a broom what the hell what is going
on you're creepy as hell what
is oh my God oh my God I can't I what is
he
doing straight on her what is did he be
her knocked her
out are we going need some answers or
something we have to right is he GNA
just drive her back to the slaughter
guy what he poking her for what is he
doing there's no no need to do
that
so creepy so
uncomfortable that's scarier than the
chainsaw guy yeah is going
on who that he's taking is that his
house what who the hell is that who oh
is that the the guy oh my God it's the
guy it's the guy I told you to stay away
from that
[Music]
graveyard
oh
and they're at the house oh they're all
in on it wonderful I told
you I you I told you never leave your
brother alone you brother oh the the
brother is is the is the killer
[Applause]
chainsaw what
oh
oh an arm
oh get up get your
Grandpa
Grandpa Grandpa's dead right I mean take
it young lady you just you just take it
easy there now but we'll we'll fix you
some supper in a few minutes
huh I don't want I I don't want whatever
the supper is where I don't want
whatever they're cooking you just take
it easy
take it
easy we have some meat right away no oh
God God don't eat the meat don't eat the
meat don't eat the meat girl this isn't
Arby's that's your friends AR friends
has your friends insides yeah I mean
like I'm saying she if she eats there
it's going to be your friends insides
[Music]
yeah what the grand grandpa is dead why
are we getting him is this the ritual
just just bury Grandpa he's gone oh my
God that's why they were up there they
just like keep their keep their dead
bodies this movie is
disturbing I weirdly think this is like
more disturbing than Z absolutely
because this is just I it's just so real
right now that I'm like I can't yeah
it's psychologically messed up and there
something like grounded and like eerie
real about it Grandpa's gone dude oh
that's the where the cutting begins are
they going to try to like if they get
her blood does it bring him back what's
going on they're trying to Res Grandpa
no not her finger not her
finger Oh I thought they're going to cut
it off they're going to feed it to
Grandpa Grandpa's dead though y'all
Grandpa's gone is he not dead is he
gonna freaking open his eyes and be
living I can't be doing that right now I
think I just saw him blinking like
moving his eyes oh my God are you for
real he sucking on him
he's alive he's sucking on her finger oh
god what the
hell oh
no oh I imagine this movie probably
traumatized the [__] out of people in
the 70s it h absolutely this is like
what is the bird what's going on bird in
the
armadillo cuz I might
never seen anything that point my God
Grandpa is
alive he's makeup on now oh God yeah
it's and it's like the carve someone
else's face she's on someone else's arms
and hands
yeah this is
awful they're taunting her oh
wow a face lamp no
no oh my God this is so messed up
[Applause]
[Music]
how is she G to get out of this all not
she's
[Music]
not do nothing he's just a
cook shut up you [__]
hog oh my God are they the chicken head
on a plate thing on the little
table
Who full closeup
shots yeah but terrifying for eyes oh
man Grandpa's the best it won't hurt a
[Applause]
bit
okay maybe now she could get out of it
if she finds a weapon and stabs
everybody
please
[Applause]
what oh my goodness come on Grandpa
Grandpa's Grandpa's half dead y'all
doesn't got it in oh my
god oh ESC my God R okay she actually
escap out another window girl okay how
did she actually Escape I don't know
thought she would be knocked out they
hit you like three times with that
Mallet right oh my Lord it is day light
how are they not chasing after her
already what's going
on oh my God that was so stressful I
hated every second of that yeah yeah oh
great here he comes at least it's a
skinny guy I
guess got
her
my God is a car going to come and then
he they're going to see her oh my God if
they don't stop I don't I don't know
what's going to happen oh are they going
to run him
over wa damn
wa oh oh yeah he's like nope okay yeah
get in the oh good for you sir good for
you
sir good
citizen oh God no no honey why are you
getting out why would you get just drive
drive
away what what are you guys doing what
now you're being stupid no no now you're
just being dumb why why did we do that
you had a car
girl oh my God if that that W God
what this is okay all right you this is
dumb that was
dumb yeah stop that girl's bloody as
hell jump in the back girl oh my God oh
my God what nope nope nope
nope oh God that sound
[Music]
what happened to the other
[Applause]
guy that it is that the end of the movie
oh oh my god oh
wow
okay okay oh my God oh my God oh God
that was okay that was a journey that
was something that was a journey that
was an experience to say the least oh
okay
um yeah I
feel uh feel gross I feel gnarly and I
feel really exhausted like yeah that the
ending of that like where they're just
you're trying to get Grandpa to hit her
was like the the worst the worst the
thing of all nightmares I don't even
know what and the guy I did think it was
cool that the guy threw something I
don't know what he threw in his eye and
then he he threw a wrench at his head a
wrench he threw cuz he they showed a
shot of him grabbing the wrench he
grabbed a wrench that makes more sense I
was like what did he throw that knocks
it knocked him down yeah and then the
chainsaw goes into him and I'm tell
telling you the last shot to me felt
very like the Joker with Wen Phoenix
when he's on the stairs he does like a
weird dance like that and I'm like oh
it's so
demented um yeah
wild thoughts Aaron oh
man like did you like it did you like
what was your favorite part my favorite
part of it that's tough uh I will say
because of the jump scare uh that part
when like we first get the reveal that
he's out there with them and he kills
the um the one dude and starts chasing
her I would say like that was the most
tense part for me
um yeah I will say this movie does a
really good job in the beginning part
the beginning half or for the first
twoth thirds of really building up
tension of like holding long shots you
know building up the uh the suspense
with all of the audio in the like the
talk about death and like all the
murders and so grim and it's just like
this very tense experience for like most
of the movie and then yeah with this
really long chase scene with him going
around and trying to get her then like
the movie does a really good job of of
encapsulating dread and having
disturbing imagery I like I said it
during their uh reaction the fact that
this is a movie that is more disturbing
than saw and saw came out like years
later and yeah I think just the nature
of it being in seems like it was an
indie movie and with it being the 70s
there's like a different standard like I
I could imagine a movie like this being
made today but watching it I see all of
the influences that in other horror
movies that I've seen like have you ever
seen movie x no no okay well this very
much reminded me of that movie X and I
was like okay I can definitely see this
movie had to walk so movies like X and
uh cabin in the woods and other
influences of Horrors could run okay
yeah I will say though um even though it
was building up tension in that that
third act it started to get a little
much for me it started to become like it
started to go on a little long and I was
like I get it we're like sitting in the
tension but I'm like okay like what are
we what are we doing iel like it was it
was like plateauing and it kind of like
lost some of its effect for me because I
was like okay we're kind of just like
sitting in this but what's happening and
I think the reason or how she got out of
it was like a little unbelievable I was
like he's holding her and like he
leather face is right there how does she
just get away and run and right I don't
know
I I I I think I liked most of it um I
don't know if like's I can't even say
like like's not like the APT word for
this experience it's a tough one to like
describe yeah yeah it's eerie and I
think it's it's it was impressive about
about being able to build up that
tension being able to to show these
these images in a way that's like cuz I
can easily see this movie being
something that's shown but is like
disgusting for disgusting sake or like
has all these images for the for the
shock value but it was really building
up like the horrific nature of what it
of what this family was yeah and even
though we don't get a lot of information
about who they are and what they do I
think a lot of the the subtext and the
the visuals kind of display and tell a
story of it in of itself and I thought
that was very impressive about the movie
yeah and in the beginning like uh with
with all of the astrology talk and
there's a lot of shots back to like the
Sun and the Moon in here they like
constantly Fade to that where that's
like having a pull and effect and what
we hear on the radio initially with like
the the bodies being dug up and then um
also just going back to them where I'm
like oh I really do think the barbecue
was it's obviously humans 100% and I'm
like oh cuz they didn't have fresh blood
I guess through this town I still think
that that is a that's probably what was
what was going down they needed fresh
blood to feed grandpa um I feel like all
of it uh the setup was um was nice in
how they brought it into the characters
initially with her being obsessed with
astrology and then them not really being
affected by the weird guy cutting his
hand in the car like nobody really
freaked out which led us to not being
super mad when they first go to the
house you're like why are you in this
guy's house the guy told you before
don't go up there no nothing really like
affects these guys um which uh I liked
which led it led me like more into the
story of following them I think like the
part where it kind of plateau as when
they're we're left with the last two we
know that they're going to end up going
to the house and well they'll probably
being killed but I did not see the
twists and turns inside of the home what
was going to happen which did keep it
very exciting for me but it was extra
disturbing like it was just so real that
they Grandpa and the it's it was just so
real that I just uh I mean you probably
yeah you can cut back to my face I mean
at the end of that I was just like I
don't even want to fully watch this for
a minute more like it was just so
disturbing gross it makes you feel
really gross like I was like oh man can
we please cut out of the shot and then
but it's it's a good way of like
cinematically pushing you to the
threshold so that when she does run away
you're like yes okay cool she got away
I'm I was only in the headset of not
even like this is dumb how could she I
was just like thank God we were out of
there like run I also think it would
have been difficult but there are a
bunch of weirdos in there and I knew it
when he untied her I was like this
skinny kid can't hold her down uh anyway
I'm I'm glad that she got away I do
think it's a it's a more fun ending with
her uh getting away uh yeah cuz they're
not going to build up all that tension
for them not to have her Escape have
somebody right some semblance of Hope
and the terar of the life that she leads
after that though you can't even live my
God scarred forever for like you're
going to be a malfunctioning human yeah
no there's no quality of life for her
probably she needs a lot of therapy
after that yeah I mean I just I do think
the foundation the way it was set the
world is like crumbling there's so much
crime and there's like Cala and then
people digging up dead bodies and then
we have this family in a town and it
just I don't
know I'm like is this how all the little
towns are like because the the news on
the radio all of it was really bad and
weird so I'm I'm wondering if that will
lead us to having more of this because
it has affected the world because
there's multiples of these right there's
more yeah I think it's a whole franchise
and I can understand how it spond to
franchise cuz I can't imagine there was
another horror movie like this prior to
this coming out cuz like it's this
Grindhouse kind of lower budget low
small casts disturbing long shots really
really setting the tone and setting the
environment of what you're about to
experience and I think that it's very
telling that we in 2023 are watching
this movie from what is it
1974 and we're still dis just as
Disturbed as they probably were if not
more when this movie came out and it's
the tension it's the the the just the
nature of everything that the movie had
put on screen it's more disturbing than
saw and saw was like had crazy images
and traps and but I think it's the
quicker editing and saw and like longer
shot of just staying on with like
Grandpa go ahead and hit her nope it
didn't move it didn't go go ahead try it
again I'm like dying inside yeah it's
it's it's it feels real through the
woods realistic right because they're
not cutting they didn't they're using a
lot of like mid shots to like masters of
her just like running and not cutting
out of them a lot to do a lot of
close-ups we're just we're just with her
on this run away from this this crazy
dude which makes it seem way more
realistic also the stuff in like the
middle like when stuff starts going down
like how they portray this uh this dude
is just like this massive like hulking
figure like the fact that he's just can
manhandle the the first guy and like
picked up the girl like it's nothing and
put her on the hook and uh what did he
do with the the third guy do we see oh
yeah he just like hit him with the club
yeah he we didn't really but just and
that was like another call back to the
to the butchering of the cows where they
were like they hit him once but they
have to hit him a few times to kill him
yeah and the first guy he did that weird
like seizuring remember I was like oh
God I didn't realize that that if you
get hit that hard like you ah it out
that was freaky yeah yeah I think a lot
of this experience was was freaky and
disturbing like I I can say I would I
would watch the song movies again I
don't know if I'd ever watch this again
oh no I can't no I have no desire I I I
I mean I can respect it but I have no
desire to see this again and I know
their screenings of this like you know
what for Halloween season I'm like I
would need to let a good 10 to 20 years
go by for me to like forget and then go
I'll revisit it CU that ending the end
part when they once they find Grandma
and Grandpa and were rocking and rolling
with Sally and her torture it is really
tough with the dad and they're all like
they're all pokers poke now to me is
like nobody poke me for the next 10 days
otherwise I'mma lose it like I will lose
it a poke freezer there it's a poke
freezer there are so many there are so
many things in this movie that I'm like
oh just I hope I can go about my day um
tomorrow and the rest of this week and
not have glimpses of what's happening in
this movie yeah because it really I
don't know yeah there there are movies
that like can kind of stick with you and
because I think saw did too but it was a
little easier for me to go like saw cool
and walk away from it I think I think I
know how to like consolidate and just be
like this this movie goes into a box and
that box goes in a trash in my brain but
I'm just saying this is a little harder
to walk away from because it felt so
real and so grounded and just yeah also
I think a part of it at least for me
that plays into it is um the fact that
in the Saw movies and I know we keep
referencing saw because we just watched
them we just watched the saw so go
you'll see the videos guys that's why
we're yeah we're talking about it but I
think in those movies the majority of
people that are being tortured are men
and I think just watching this girl go
through this experience with like this
this really big dude and like these
these two like unhinged uh father and
son and just all of them and how help
how helpless and how scared she is and
the screaming of her just makes it just
like all that much more um disturbing
and hard to sit through and I know this
is like a a cult classic I know people
really like really love this movie but I
get one I understand why from like the
the first two acts of the movie and like
how it builds up tension
and yeah how how it's an influence for
sure I just um yeah man this was it's a
it's a classic for a reason I get it but
uh yeah really disturbing film it's a
great suspense thriller I mean the shots
are cool uh he they did take a lot lot
of like um cool liberties with the
Cinematic shots especially towards the
end I really liked when the creepy dad
guy got in the in the truck and it was
driving her back to the house that light
on his face that was a cool shot I say
that it's such a cool shot the close-ups
of her eyes like what this movie I do
also really appreciate which I'll just
point out real quick is the close-up of
her eyes gave me so much anxiety at
first I was like beautiful shot cool
shot of the eye wow they got a really
closeup and then they kept on there and
it made me feel claustrophobic and all
it all came bubbling up um I I really I
did really like this movie it came it
brought some stuff up so that's like it
did what it set up to do it did it did
it did its job uh I was scared that jump
scare was terrifying everybody in here
did a great job I believed all of them
uh I would give
it h an eight out of 10 I mean for like
a suspense horror Thriller
like is good I didn't it did the J
yeah I would
say it's one of those movies that
um I wouldn't say it's one of my
favorite movies but I will say it's it's
well hard right like I can't be like for
me this can't be like a favorite cuz
it's so the end there was really hard
for me to watch I'm so glad she got away
and that he got cut by his own chainsaw
that was awesome also before I rate I
just want to say that was really dumb
why the guy get out of the car why go
you have a
ass man man you have a whole ass uh 16
wheer that was semi that was dumb as
hell but uh I will say because of uh the
nature and the fact that this is a
horror movie and even though it was made
back in the 70s and it's still able to
invoke these feelings in spite of the
fact that there's so many advancements
advancements in technology and film
making that since it's come out since
when this was released yeah I will say
that uh yeah it was uh as far as horror
movies goes it was a successful
experience and it was great uh
so I got to knock off a point for that
that part at the end cuz I was like that
was just that was dumb I'm like I guess
you could you could write it off with
they're like he the chainsaw he's
hearing out in the door I'm like bro you
could have hit the gas and been out of
there by by so that part was like come
on but then people do dumb things when
they're scared so I'm like I guess I can
CH it up to that but I would say I would
give it a 7.5 for me yeah all right
about where it sits Wolf The Texas
Chainsaw Massacre we did it we made it
through it may stick with us negatively
for a day or so it's a great it's a
great film but yes I don't know if I
could watch it again for a little while
so that's it uh let us know what you
guys think I mean do you watch us every
Halloween season let us know if you do
are you like distracted a lot of the
time like you're not you're not like in
it like we were right like is this bad
you're walking around doing dishes
because this is intense yeah um any who
uh leave a like leave a comment become
super sexy join patreon we love you guys
so much uh any last words before we get
out of here uh I'm going to go take a
shower who that sounds that sounds good
I'm gonna go have a drink a strong one
maybe I'll get a martini Amen to that we
love you guys so much thanks for
watching scary movies with us and we
will see you later
[Applause]
[Music]
bye